i'm very happy to talk about the fact
that i have a junk drawer actually like
five of them in the kitchen just packed
with old electronics and cables and
cords and everything and they don't go
to anything everybody needs a good
controller we all have and i'm trying to
manage so many different cables uh and
people in europe have the same problem
just like us they're inconvenienced
they're people too regulators over there
have negotiated a deal with all the tech
companies for every tech product you can
think of to standardize the cord so
they'll only be one charger that works
for everything headphones video game
consoles oh you name it it's game
changer that is a game changer it is a
game we have that here can we join the
european union is that a thing
this is amazing that is pretty cool
we've been waiting for that forever i
know apparently it could come here
because you know these companies don't
want to make multiple things one for
europe one for us so it might just
become standardized you know there's big
business in multiple courts right
they're all make a new one you got to
buy a new one maybe one got a binder all
right